voici le robot construit par cette jeune
habitant de trappes l'engin filoguidé a
nécessité plus de quatre mois de travail
ses auteurs goûte aujourd'hui le plaisir
de le conduire
ces enfants du centre socioculturel
annette moreau de trappes participent
aux trophées de la robotique organisé
par l'association planète sciences ils
s'entraînent en vue de la finale
régionale qui opposera ce samedi une
quarantaine d'équipés à montigny le
bretonneux laventure a ravi tous les
participants qui peuvent compter sur le
soutien indéfectible de leurs parents en
fait à construire va complètement à
partir juste quelques électrique d'un
moteur et de plein d'autres choses et
pour moi ça construire un robot le
manipule est que ça c'est très bien
c'est bien c'est la famille action
commencée c'était la petite boule de
poils et nos maîtres l'expérience semble
avoir inspiré à ces petites têtes de
grandes ambitions
ingénieur en robotique à l'issue de la
compétition les équipes gagnantes
participeront à la finale nationale les
1er et 2 avril prochains
celle ci en fera partie sans aucun doute